hi everyone it's jerry i just recently
learned that hikaru nakamura has an
account on leeches.org
and when i checked out his history
it showed that he played a couple games
against rey enigma
just the other day i posted a video
showing a game between rey enigma and
anatoly karpov
from the show spain's got talent and i
thought it'd be fun to check out the two
three-minute blitz games casual
that
caro and ray enigma played on
leeches.org i haven't seen the games so
i'm seeing them along with you for the
first time
using this real time feature i do know
the result of each game but as far as
what moves were played
this is this is a first for me so
we'll see in this first one
uh nakamura
has the white pieces and for some reason
there's a big delay here
uh what was that was there a handicap
we're not getting oh okay
i'm not sure what that delay was right
there
i guess uh maybe some kind of handicap
about 20 seconds was spent right there
um maybe just sorting some things out i
guess
but
yeah let's see this one so what is black
set up here going for a hippopotamus
a little aggressive on the queen side
the idea here is to meet any pawn break
by white
any attempt at a pawn break
with a push keep it closed
b4
we do have a sense of the clocks
nakamura currently down just a little
bit
black in the think tank
the c4 square is opened up that's a a
positive
now that the a4 and b4 are in there
something that white has gained f1 is
opened up for the knight to maneuver
where to go at some point this could be
captured if you do take right away yeah
that knight c6 move is a double attack
and you get the pawn back
so no quick bite on b4
a5 some space it also rules out knight
to a5 knight going for its king side
journey
to what square it might even go to h2i i
think maybe h2 something like h5 g5
knight h2 into g4 could be a nice pivot
so some serious space all across the
board
yeah we do have h5 now putting a big
dent in black's camp
carving out a square on f5
black not too quick to budge
yeah i think in fact if if g5 straight
away you might have seen first g4 and
then knight g3
and then there'd be a knight planted on
that f5 square
so i guess bishop here
this is the bad guy
probably want to get it functioning
somewhere on the king side though we
have to watch out for knight g4 here
under control twice clock situation
nakamura is still with two minutes plus
and a minute 20
team black
not going too well
i do have the engine running it does
like
white by a couple points here
now c5 break
more secure king for white c5 nearby
a little airy over here yeah c5
where's this bishop even go you might
even consider c6
taking away every single square but i
mean it's super sensible of course to
rip open the position as well
i think any environment structurally
white's gonna be better
king position is the big one there we go
bishop lands on a4
queen only had one square had to run
back home now there's bishop b6 oh and
she's dead
down the exchange there
big trouble
42 seconds to two minutes
huge
huge edge on the clock and position
the game continues now we have f5 i
guess the knights angling for f4
queen back home has there been a black
piece on white side of the board yet i
don't think so
all right maybe maybe we're going to get
that soon night on f4 but it'll it'll be
easily worked around
the bishop can always fall back to f1 to
offset it yeah there
you have one good piece but it's under
control by this guy right here and now
the pigs are gonna arrive on the seventh
shortly maybe even right now knight f5
now knight g5 nearby 24 seconds for
black
to a minute 39
brutal
absolutely brutal
withdrawing the rook the knight was
attacking
you can't go here i got a couple pieces
here in
white's house but i don't think that
there's going to be enough
enough pieces around to do any damage to
team white this is super secure
even have the rook assisting
f2 can maybe be a sensitive point also
the knight is securing any g3 break
yeah the queen's entering problem on
this square you could probably take even
yeah that's
that's when that one's gone there's
queen g6 here and then rook here fault
well that's the final move of the game
a little black timed out here but it's
going to be made anyhow
king here the rook gets to the back rank
take a bishop maybe take a queen take a
rook
what's that it's a mating four in the
end
okay that was the first game they only
played two so let's have a look at the
uh the second one
throw on the real time once more
and that'll be it
okay so this one oh let me look from
nakamura's perspective he's playing
black in this one
okay
let us see
no slow start this time
this is a big weakness on e4
i'd like to get this exchange in
okay knight e4
now this knight could be driven back
at some point how we dealing with this
guy
and where will the bishop go okay to c4
you don't want to play this too soon
there'd be bishop takes e6
so what do we do we try and get the
bishop off
no maybe get the knight to f6 knight f6
into d5 possibly
c5 is a break
he's the two invasive pieces how to cope
with them
238 to 223 on the clock
all right c5 first
and what
if this you could probably take the
knight exchange queens take here it
should be a superior structure
for black
now there might be some accident
happening shortly on these squares
starting to intersect so that night is
chopped
i got a space invader pawn here both of
them are
i like i like a white's pawn better than
black's pawn because there's a pawn
supporting it
so it's an it's an invasive pawn
but it's uh
it's it's it's it's secure pretty well
so same color bishops
challenging that space invader pawn you
had to take with the pawn then there'd
be a big square here some pressure on
the pawn better bishop for nakamura and
space now that there isn't the pawn on
e5 for white anymore
so what do we do trying to get one rook
off i think the king would love to be on
e6 right about now clock situation
not as big as an advantage as the
first game two minutes
to a minute 36
still an edge
a lot of pawns on dark squares
not the greatest coordination between
structure and bishop for white
all right king arriving soon on e6 the
rook can be planted here
maybe this one yes that's a that's a
timely move
given a moment black would like to get
this in so at least there is some
possible target for this guy but how do
you see
how does this bishop get freed oh boy
i guess i guess the plan here is to go
into a complete prevent king probably
wants to come over here
yeah maybe this pawn is going to be
tracked down right
yeah this is excellent for black
yeah you could afford a rook exchange
rook here
or you could have even waited too
because
the this bishop is supporting it
so he's gonna he's gonna clamp down in
this position entirely
pawn right here
and this bishop is getting embarrassed
tough day at the office for this guy
has to resort to back and forth mode now
this is going to be scooped up what
about the rook up and over
and then hunt this pawn double isolated
pawns
their uh outside pass oh this rook is
getting some activity
okay but this guy is passed
and next up this one and then here take
advantage of the pin one minute for team
white
124 for nakamura
pawns are running
i wonder if there was was there a way
that this rook is
you know could you have done it where
this rook doesn't even have
this kind of activity
41 seconds for white
minute 21
rook ready to get behind the pawn
king stops that
you could go into a pin
this bishop isn't around well maybe
bishop here there's that move
but then this is this a shot right now
possibly c4
no
the king is the king is inching over
yeah this isn't uh this isn't clear
wow
still have these guys too
king here and then bishop here
could promote whenever you want 20
seconds for white to a minute for black
he proponed it to a knight
a little flash there
you gonna go after this guy
this this one might dart yeah the bishop
says i'll take care of that pawn
okay you have to take here and then try
to run here this is getting a little
dangerous for black
pawn here and then rook here yeah he had
to sacrifice the bishop for the two
pawns rook and pawn ending
super active rook
how are we stopping this guy
the king is there to assist
there
the king gets here in time
the computer's saying it's a zero
eight seconds
a zero on board
evaluation-wise
and
oh that's the final move of the game
a white offer to draw
and it was accepted
ah okay well
that was
an equal position in the end
um
that was quite the comeback i would say
because that bishop was a really really
bad piece and i'm surprised to see the
uh
the draw by mutual agreement i mean he
could he could have flagged him clearly
if he wanted to 26 seconds for nakamura
in the in this final position to six
okay well that was interesting i just
wanted to share these two
uh games
especially since i recently covered a
game
between rey enigma and anatoly karpov
i thought that's
that
game was neat and maybe you found this
one interesting so feel free to leave
any feedback to this video in the
comment section below hope you enjoyed
it and found a little fun
that's all for now take care bye
you